[Music]
[Music]
jon snow was originally supposed to kill
the night king on game of thrones arya
stark killed the night king in the final
season of game of thrones during the
battle for winterfell
but according to the cast it wasn't
always supposed to go that way
a few days ago mazie williams an actress
who played darya stark revealed that kit
harrington
an actor who plays jon snow told her and
everyone else that he was going to go
that way
quoting kit someone told me in season 3
that i was going to kill the night king
and this is what should have happened
that would have given us a satisfying
conclusion to jon snow's story
that would have fulfilled the long-built
prophecy of jon snow being the prince
that was promised
that would have justified rhaegar and
his obsession with prophecies as well
especially because creating jon snow who
rhaegar believed would be the prince
that was promised
it cost rhaegar his own life as well as
lives of his both
wives lyanna who died giving birth to
jon and rhaegar's first wife elia
the children rehgar had vitalia were
also brutally killed
the mad king died as well as tens of
thousands of soldiers on both sides
all these deaths the end of the long
targaryen dynasty just because rhaegar
thought
jon had to be created only for all of it
including josh 2 heritage not to be
important at the end at all
john killing the night king would have
justified why jon snow was brought back
to life
it would have justified all the build up
to this epic fight between the night
king and jon snow
that's been building for years all of
that to be for nothing
just because the showrunners david
benioff and then weiss decided it would
be too obvious for jon to kill the night
king
which was the original plan and changed
it to biaria
don't be fooled by thinking ariel's
planned to kill the night king all along
and don't think it was for shadow to
happen way back in season 3 when
melisandre made a prophecy to her about
shutting the blue eyes among the others
that she would repeat to her in season 8
before she kills the night king
that arya melisandre seen very merely
sandre reminds her of the eyes she would
shot forever
and how the blue eyes are the only left
from the prophecy well it wasn't
foreshadowing anything
yes zarya did kill the night king who
has blue eyes but at the time
melisandre first made his prophecy to
arya as i already mentioned
it was back in season 3 in 2013. do you
know when the showrunners decided it
would be arya who kills the night king
in 2016 after season 8 episode 3 the
battle for winner fell aired
the showrunners revealed that they made
a decision 3 years ago
that it would be arya to kill the leader
of the white walkers this was in 2019
which means david
benioff and then wise decided around
2016.
after season 6 was made that it would be
arya who kills the night king
this confirms melisandre's prophecy had
nothing to do with the night king
as this scene took place in 2013 and it
was three years after the scene that the
showrunner switched from jon to arya to
kill the night king
arya's whole story was about vengeance
and her years of training with the
faceless men were justified when she
avenged killing of her family when she
avenged the red wedding by using faces
to kill walder frey
she could have also used those faces to
kill cersei and once again avenge her
family
that was her story not the white walkers
and not the night king
they were jon snow's story since season
1. arya killing the night king makes as
much sense as if jon snow ended up
killing walder frey or cersei
because that simply is not what his
story was built up to when the word of
his father ned stark's fate reaches the
wall
john initially wants to ride south and
join rob in vengeance for his father but
he doesn't because lord commander jor
mormont
convinces him that those wars and the
game of thrones are not important
because there's only one war that
matters and it's against the white
walkers
arya had nothing to do with the white
walker story she didn't know they even
existed until the very final season
while jon's whole story on the other
hand was about the white walkers and the
great war that was coming
in season 1 episode 1 john snow is with
his father
when a deserter of the night's watch is
brought before ned to be executed
that deserter named well who ran away
after seeing the white walkers kill his
fellow brothers of the night's watch
tells them what he saw the white walkers
ned executes him because that is the law
for abandoning the night's watch
so jon is involved in the whole story
since the very beginning
during season 1 he's a man to kill the
first bite in a thousands of years
when the corpse brought back to the wall
becomes white and attacks lord commander
mormont
john saves mormon's life by burning a
bite earning a pardon for his earlier
misdemeanor
as well as valyrian steel sword longclaw
in season 2 jon's story continues to be
about the threat beyond the wall
as they ride north of the wall seeking
for benjen and an explanation for the
white attack
john sees craster carrying a newborn
into the woods leaving a child for a
while walker as a sacrifice
in season 3 jon and the three folk
arrive at the fist of the first men
only to survey the bloody aftermath of
the assault on the night's watch by the
white walkers
and their army of whites in season 4
john takes a little break from the white
walker story due to the threat of the
wildings
but he's still very much aware that they
are out there advising stannis to burn
the bodies of the dead wildings in order
to prevent them from returning as whites
in season 5 the white walker story gets
him killed
john makes a hard choice and does what
he believes is the best
and that's rescuing the free folk from
hardhome and allowing them to pass the
wall and settle in the north to keep
them from falling into the hands of the
coming white walker army
as he knows that if they stay out there
they will be killed then resurrected
and added to the ever-growing army of
the undead while doing so hard home is
attacked by the night king's army
and jon fights the white walker and
kills him with longclaw the night king
watches at jon intensely with interest
from a distance
the night king and jon share a long
glance with each other as the night king
uses his magic to raise all of the dead
as wides before jon's eyes
still jon saved some of the free folk
from dying and joining the white walker
army
and allowed them to go south of the wall
which got him killed
in season 6 john is resurrected by
melisandre and the lord of light
because he still has a role to play in
the great war in the aftermath of his
victory at winterfell and the
confirmation from the citadel that
winter has come
jon snow warns the gathered lords of the
north and the veil
who wish to return home that the war is
not over alluding at the coming of the
night king
in season 7 john prepares the north for
the upcoming great war against the white
walkers
upon receiving two letters one an
invitation from tyrion to come and meet
dany dragonstone
and the second from sam informing him of
his discovery of dragonglass on
dragonstone
john decides to go to dragonstone risk
his life
because that's the only chance for the
north to win this war jon leads a
mission to capture a white and prove the
cersei that the threat is real
and hopes to put a stop on fighting
among the living and get the support of
the lannister army as well
jon fights a white walker again kills
bunch of wights and once again shares a
glance with the night king
not once but two times as you can see
the white walkers were the core of jon's
story
they were his purpose and his destiny
and few days ago it's confirmed that jon
snow was originally supposed to be the
one to kill the night king
as it's revealed kids said they told him
in season 3 it would be his character
jon snow killing the night king
which makes complete sense the night
king's actor was changed because they
planned to have the night king vs jon
snow epic fight
where jon snow prevails hence friday is
fetched from an actual actor playing the
night king
one of the world's best swordsmen and 33
years experienced stuntmen
all of this buildup for years and years
was destroyed when in 2016 after the
release of season 6
the showrunners came to a conclusion
they left way too many clues of jon
being the one to kill the night king
and instead of giving us a satisfying
conclusion to jon's story and have him
kill the night king
the show runners changed it to arya and
went for a shock value instead
their explanation on why they decided
for it to be arya who kills the night
king
instead of jon whose entire story from
season 1 up until season 8 was building
for this great showdown between him and
the night king
which was supposed to fulfill his
destiny wrap up his story perfectly
benny of said we hope to kind of avoid
the expected
and jon snow has always been the hero
the one who's been the savior
but it just did not seem right to us for
this moment john was literally made for
this moment
while it's arya's first time seeing why
walkers and whites and the night king
you cannot make all that build up and
throw it away just because you want to
avoid the expected
good writing should be more valued than
the shock value i'm going to leave the
last words to none other than george rr
martin
who perfectly explained why changing the
story plot just because people expect
it's not a good choice as it takes away
the satisfaction of the build
up makes all the planet glows and
foreshadows at that end
and ultimately ruins everything i mean
would you change your plot lines if you
discovered them
at someone someone had guessed as to
your conclusion you know i would not
um these people have figured out
something should i now change it
and i decided that way late disaster you
know i'd laid in
clues and things that pointed to a
particular thing and if i now
changed it because one person in a
thousand had figured it out
the new solution would not be
satisfactory because the clues point in
another way would be
it would be a cheat in a sense and then
a thousand puts it on an
internet message board and everybody
sees it and they say oh yeah yeah that's
right
no now i see the clues i got it and
pretty soon half
the readership or at least the internet
savvy portion of your readership
knows it but what do you do then do you
change it and come up with something
goofy and outlandish that you haven't
led the you haven't done the
the foreshadowing for that you haven't
laid the foundation for
just in order to surprise people i mean
sure i could have like aliens come down
and that would certainly
surprise the howard of everybody no one
is predicting that but
it would ruin the series so uh thank you
guys so much for watching i hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did please
give it a big thumbs up and i hope to
see you in the next one
peace